WASHINGTON, D.C. UP NEXT.
[♪♪]
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD EVENING
AND WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE HIS FIRST
STATE OF THE UNION.
WHAT WAS STRIKES IS HOW ORDINAR
WHAT WAS STRIKES IS HOW ORDINARY
IT WAS.
YOU HEARD BROAD APPEALS TO
NATIONAL UNITY AND CALLS FOR
STRONG BORDERS AND YOU HEARD
WARM WORDS FOR THE COUNTRY'S
BEDROOM INSTITUTIONS FROM THE
FAMILY TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS.
OUTSIDE THE FACULTY LOUNGE MOST
AMERICANS LIKE THESE THINGS,
THEY AGREE WITH THEM.
DONALD TRUMP REMAINS
CONTROVERSIAL AS A PERSON BUT
THE BULK OF HIS POSITIONS ARE
NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
CHECK THE POLLING.
AND THE KEY THING TO KNOW ABOUT
THE CURRENT POLITICS, IT'S
LAST NIGHT'S STATE OF THE UNION
WAS NOT DELIVERED IN A BRITISH
ACCENT.
DEMOCRATS DID NOT APPLAUD.
THINGS DEMOCRATS ONCE AGREED
WITH.
HE HAS CHANGED THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BUT NOT NEARLY AS MUCH AS
HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS CHANGED
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU JUST RETURNED FROM A YEAR
ABROAD, PREPARE YOURSELF, YOU
WILL NOT RECOGNIZE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
LAST NIGHT DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
REFUSE TO STAND OR CLAP WHEN HE
PRAISED THE MILITARY OR VETERANS
AND WHAT IF IT'S MORE THAN
RESISTANCE.
WHAT IF DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY DON'T
LIKE THOSE THINGS ANYMORE.
WHAT IF PRAISING OUR VETERANS OR
FLAGS ENRAGES THE MODERN LEFT.
DURING A TWEET DURING THE IS
SPEECH, THERE WAS A QUOTE,
CHURCH, FAMILY, POLICE,
MILITARY, THE NATIONAL ANTHEM,
TRUMP TRYING TO CALL ON ALL THE
TROPES OF 1950s ERA NATIONALISM.
TERMS OF BYGONE ERA.
THINK OF THAT FOR A SECOND,
POLICE, MILITARY, LOVE OF
COUNTRY ARE NOW TROPES FROM A
BYGONE ERA.
MOST AMERICANS CONSIDER THEM THE
PILLARS OF OUR ORGANIZATION.
WITHOUT THOSE THINGS WOULD YOU
WANT TO LIVE THERE?
JOY REED WOULD OR HER CO-ANCHORS
AT MSNBC AND HER HARVARD CLASS
MATES.
THE WORDS DISGUST THEM.
IT'S NOT A POLITICAL RESISTANCE.
IT'S ANILISM.
TO TEAR DOWN WHAT YOU DID NOT
TRANSLATED IN POLITICAL TERMS.
A POLITICS THAT ELEVATES ALL
THAT IS UGLY AND DECK
THAT IS UGLY AND DECAD
THAT IS UGLY AND DECADEN
THAT IS UGLY AND DECADENT.
IT'S A SICKNESS AND ONCE YOU
CATCH IT YOU'RE APT TO SAY
WHICH HE SOUNDS LIKE THE BIGGEST
ISSUE IN THE UNITED STATES IS
MS-13, A GANG NOBODY BUT FOX
NEWS HAS EVER HEARD OF.
>> FOR THIS PRESIDENT TO
CONFLATE THE DREAMERS WITH GANG
MEMBERS -- HE WAS DEMONIZING OUR
IMMIGRANTS AND I WAS OFFEND.
>> Tucker: SO MS-13 IS MERELY
SOMETHING FOX NEWS CREATE TO
DEMONIZE IMMIGRANTS.
PRESUMABLY THE IMMIGRANTS THE
GANG ROUTINELY KILLS BECAUSE
THEY ONLY KILL IMMIGRANTS.
WE DON'T WANT TO THINK THE LEFT
REALLY BELIEVES THIS BUT WE'RE
STARTING TO THINK THEY DO.
ON ANOTHER CHANNEL, A
CONTRIBUTOR SAID FAMILY WAS
OFFENSIVE.
TO ME THAT CRYSTALLIZED THE
RESPONSE.
>> THE VIEW IS WHO ARE YOU GOING
TO BELIEVE, POLLS TAKEN BY
MUCH WEIGHT AND MANY ANSWERED TO
THE POLLS SO EITHER YOU BELIEVE
THEM OR BELIEVE PUNDITS THAT DO
THEIR UPON
THEIR UPO
THEIR POO
THEIR PONT
THEIR PONTIF
THEIR PONTIFIC
THEIR PONTIFICAT
THEIR PONTIFICATIN
THEIR PONTIFICATING
THEIR PONTIFICATING F
THEIR PONTIFICATING FRO
THEIR PONTIFICATING FROM
THEIR PONTIFICATING FROM S
IN NEW YORK AND WASHINGTON.
ALL I CAN THINK OF 2016 AND THE
ELECTION AND PENNSYLVANIA AND
THE FACT THAT ONE GOT CLOSE TO
OF THE COUNTRY.
WE SEE THE ANALYSIS OF TODAY,
ASTOUNDING NUMBERS.
CNN SAW RESPONDENTS WERE SPEECH
AND SOMEWHAT HIGHER.
UNITE THE COUNTRY RATHER THAN
DIVIDE IT YET ALL WE HEARD FROM
PUNDITS SIT WAS GLOOMY AND
DIVISIVE AND 73% THOUGHT THEY
WERE POSITIVE BUT IF YOU DIDN'T
WATCH THE SPEECH YOU WOULD THINK
IT'S THE MOST DARKEST -- THAT'S
A DOUBLE NEGATIVE, THE DARKEST
SPEECH WE'VE HEARD FROM A
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: IT'S LIKE THERE'S A
DISCONNECT FROM WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND THOSE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO REPORT THE NEWS AND
GATHERING IT.
TOGETHER A FOOTBALL TEAM WITH.
THERE'S 70,000 MEMBERS IN LONG
ISLAND AND IN JERSEY THEY
COMMITTED 25 MURDERS IN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES SINCE 20 16.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY MURDERS WERE
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD OR MINE,
LET'S SEE, MINE, HOW MANY WERE
HONDURAN OR OTHERS, 100%.
HOW IS IT JUST IMMIGRANTS.
>> HE EXTENDED HIS DACA PROPOSAL
TO 1.8 MILLION.
HOW CAN HE PROPOSE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND BE ANTI-IMMIGRANT
AT THE SAME TIME.
IT'S A WALKING CONTRADICTION.
>> Tucker: YOU WONDER IF THERE'S
ANYONE AT THE NETWORKS WONDERING
WHAT LIFE AFTER TRUMP LOOKS LIKE
OR DE VALUE YOUR CREDIBILITY,
BECAUSE THEY HAVE, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN HE'S GONE?
>> OH, BOY, IT'S GOING TO BE A
COMPLETE DISASTER.
THE ONLY REASON WHY RATE
THE ONLY REASON WHY RATIN
THE ONLY REASON WHY RATINGS
THE ONLY REASON WHY RATINGS A
THE ONLY REASON WHY RATINGS ARE
BECAUSE OF DONALD TRUMP AND THE
VITRIOL TOWARDS HIM.
YOU HAVE PUNDITS ANTI-TRUMP
TELLING AUDIENCES ON THE
NETWORKS WHAT THEY WANT TO HEAR
AND THAT'S COMFORT FOOD.
ON THEIR PHONES AFTERWARDS
THEY'RE CHECKING TWITTER AND IF
THEY'RE CONTRADICTORY IN TERMS
OF NOT BEING ANTI-TRUMP AND WE
SAW THIS WITH VAN JONES AFTER
THE ADDRESS TO THE JOINT SESSION
OF CONGRESS THE PRAISED THE PRED
PRESIDENT AND GOT BULLIED AND
SAID WAIT, LET ME CLARIFY.
AT THIS POINT HAVE YOU ANCHORS
AND PUNDITS AFRAID THEIR
AUDIENCES WILL TURN ON THEM
UNLESS THEY SAY EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANT TO HEAR AND IT'S TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME AS WELL AS,
IF YOU SUFFER FROM THAT FOR MORE